Apple says many of its most popular products are vulnerable to hacking...
…and is urging millions of its users to make security updates...
…and to do it now.
The warning says hackers could gain control of some devices, including its iPhones.
Michael George is here with the latest.
Michael, I was one of many busy making that update yesterday.
Good morning.
A lot of people were doing that.
When we usually get that notification "update our phones",...
…a lot of us ignore it, but this time, experts say don't wait.
There's a security loophole that could let hackers take control of your phone,...
…and the latest update can fix it.
Apple users going to the tech giant's updated page will find easy fix instructions...
…on what to do next to prevent a break-in to their devices.
But Apple also explains quote, "For the protection of our customers,...
…Apple doesn't disclose, discuss, or confirm security issues...
…until an investigation has occurred...
…and patches or releases are generally available."
This is what we call a zero-day vulnerability,...
…when it's been exploited by hacker before the company, in this case Apple,...
…have detected it and been able to do something about it.